[Music]  being a young black gay kid growing up  in my neighborhood they would say quiet  girl quiet girl and i'll go whoa  but this is what helped us to create the  sounds of bounce music  i'm the one and only from new orleans  louisiana  got a phone call adam been shot i just  lost my baby brother  there's a story of gun violence in  america that people are not talking  about  new orleans is one of the most dangerous  cities you know my kids carry guns and  they're in middle school  i lost my brother and my cousin too is  violence  it's time for a change i have a platform  and i need to use it as much as i can  i think it's important to focus on  saving one person at a time  you can change your life for real and  we're here to help you  it will take us as a community to end  the gun violence  the violence must stop  you